[Music]
the forum has hosted every big musical
act he can think of but in its older
years it's really had to battle for
attention with its younger crosstown
rival the Staples Center the forum
reopened in January after a massive
makeover let's check it out
over here you got some of the Eagles
equipment the first performers in the
new forum to give the forum a proper
facelift the Madison Square Garden
company has spent a hundred million
bucks on renovations it was arguably
most important music venue in the world
at one time nobody does it better than
MSG as you've seen in the garden and he
really saw them the opportunity to
return it to its original splendor and
more we came in and ripped everything
out took the seats out you know
basically gutted the building
[Music]
there's one thing that really makes this
the premier concert venue maybe not just
in the US maybe around no I got it
one thing the sound Don Henley says this
is the best sounding building in the
world that's coming from a guy who knows
and it's no accident they they put sound
baffling everywhere it was already a
great sounding building top acts are
taking notice
kiss and DEF LEPPARD will make a summer
tour stop at the Forum in July and in
August it will play host to the MTV
Video Music Awards the Miley Cyrus made
a splash last year while the rockers
wait to play they can hang in stylish
hangout rooms the games room were
sweated up in the fitness room okay now
I get to test my fear of heights we are
now on the tension grid way at the top
of the forum if you're a lighting expert
somebody who would normally have to get
harnessed up here you can just walk
along kind of Star Wars like and I also
noticed you guys have your own mood
lighting here at the Forum yes we have
over 600 LEDs in the sky we caught our
starry night okay that is cool pretty
incredible huh
[Music]